[Music]
are you on okay I'm on now we want to
start we want to start back strong uh
it's been it's been 3 weeks or so yep
woo yeah that was a good long longer
break than I think we've taken from this
podcast since we started it I was uh I
was I was in the Communist Utopia of
Cuba o hey oh for a week oh yeah over
the break yeah I mean I was at a resort
so like that's obviously just the you
know the thing that the indulgent like
white people well not just white
actually it's pretty Multicultural I got
to be honest at the hotel a lot of
Russians too because Cuba is one of the
only countries that the Russians are
allowed to go to and they've had like
long-standing relationships with them oh
yeah of course that goes way back I
guess Eric did you get a vacation I just
relaxed I enjoyed the time off the
podcast actually I didn't I felt like
something was missing for the last
couple weeks little bit little bit
um yeah yeah didn't do much though just
kind of kept in shape tried not to eat
too much yep get back into the holiday
spirit still been a little uh laggy
since uh covid but it's coming back lots
of lots of kids new new children in the
family say hi to them I had a fam
location which is very very much a of
vacation ah yeah
giant new
family many many screaming members of
the family but anyway um and I got to
say just real quick the best thing about
that Cuban resort was it was adults only
got to say no children around at all and
it was quite fantastic see that's I
would be yeah there you go and the
average AG was probably like 55 too I
felt extremely young there which was it
was nice honestly if I was younger I
might have been like this sucks there's
like no party people but like now in my
30s I'm just like sweet like it's just
relaxing
yeah we're we're at that age now at
least like where you remember being like
the kids under the table you're the
young ones in the family everybody's
looking to you to fill the shoes of the
Next Generation and now and then you
kind of go maybe you go through like a
teen phase and you're a little bit
distant and now being in the 30s and
back it's like now I just feel
completely irrelevant like I'm not
having kids some of my cousins have kids
I'm just like a holdover from some
earlier bygone era
they still have to feed me and pretend
they like me but I'm just there taking
up space I always remember this old Lou
C joke when he like he turned 40 he was
just like you know 40 is that weird age
where like no one's impressed by
anything you do anymore people are just
like yeah of course it's like I just did
this accomplishment it's like yeah
you're 40 of course shut the [__] up
like you should be doing that right it's
like there's nothing cool anymore about
like what you you're accomplishments I
mean we're not there yet but we will be
there soon [__] shovel the driveway
you idiot and then
I get nothing I get nothing anymore it's
depressing no one told you Eric this was
a great driveway shovel good job yeah no
one did that I like look and I even peed
my name in the lawn there too nobody's
impressed anymore no then they call the
cops on
you Victor in your in your forray to the
Communist Utopia did you speak to any of
these Russians or did you overhear any
of them perhaps talking about about the
end of History which seems to have
affected them uh disproportionately no I
can't say I can't say that I that I did
uh I actually talked to one person who I
thought was Russian but it turned out
they were Ukrainian from living in
Canada and they just told me how
uncomfortable they felt with all the
Russians around ah woo you need a safe
space for everybody right yeah exactly
exactly but uh no I didn't notice them I
didn't notice them telling me anything
about how history was
over oh God there's two Wars going on
I mean checking out was AFK checking out
is quite a releas wait have you guys
seen that show years and years a BBC
show I just started watching it it's
like kind of sci-fi like alternate
universe I think they made it in 2019
and it's about basically like watching
the British government devolve into like
an authoritarian State and there's like
this politician in Britain and she's
being interviewed on some news show and
she's just like this is obviously before
the Israeli Palestine thing happened
when they made it and someone was like
well what do you think about the Israeli
palestin situation and then she just
like turns to the camera and is like I
don't give a [__] about it and then like
people started clapping and there she's
just like you know I'm worried about
what's going on home and it was just
like funny to me that they inserted that
as the example to show like to depict a
politician kind of expressing this
desire in the public to just be like I
don't want to care about things that are
happening in other parts of the world
and it's funny that that was used as
like a hook to show like why people
would be attracted to it basically to be
able to say
I don't want to think about those things
anymore and like a politician telling
them like yeah you don't have to think
about those things anymore who cares I
feel like this is going to be a line
that we hear more and more this was a
fiction obviously but it it seems like
there's a bit of there's a bit of
burnout well felt it felt it that's why
I'm mentioning because it felt like it
was capturing something that like maybe
exists in The Ether although the show
was made a while honestly really good
show that's kind of how history works we
we have that expression where something
doesn't age well
right because because of events and then
in hindsight it looks bad it like
current events shed new light or make
things look a little different in the
past and I mean a good sign that that
history is happening is is when that
happens I think you watch an old movie
or something and you go my God that
wouldn't be that wouldn't fly anymore
didn't age well yeah okay but but
getting to the topic itself can I just
like preface it by saying to that like
conversations about history or like
philos philosophies of history have
always confused me like I've always felt
confused by the discussion when people
talk about like oh there's a philosophy
but then people will say well there's no
such thing as history or history is not
and
so I guess I'm just prefacing by by
saying it's always been something that I
don't really know what we're talking
about when we say like people will
invoke this category history and I don't
know what they mean and it feels like
different people mean different things
like I've you know some philosophers
will be like well there's no history or
there's no linear history history is
cyclical and I'm just like what the [__]
are we talking about are we just talking
about sequences of events happening I
don't know I don't know what the hell
we're talking about so hopefully and
this book didn't help we should talk
then about what we're talking about I
gave you I I gave you a whole diagram
Victor did that not help at all oh it
did it did a little bit hey what's going
on in your head as a podcast we're gonna
be pretty good on this I don't think
that we're going to agree necessarily on
all this but the idea of History doesn't
mean mean one thing if you're if you are
of the critical theory persuasion or the
philosophy persuasion as opposed to the
critical theory persuasion there's going
to be a number of little uh bells that
this jingles in your mind not least the
main book that we're reading which is
called the end of history and the last
men but it's not the only book we're
going to read no but we're starting with
but I guess we could we could go around
and ask do you think history is over we
could go around the table and start with
that but I I want to say I mentioned
this to someone who's an Nory I guess
you could say someone who doesn't have
academic philosophy background and they
were just like what the hell are you
talking about that isn't that makes no
sense to even suggest that history is
over yeah it's kind of a weird idea when
you just hear it without context but I I
I assume that some of those people are
probably listening so instead of trying
to jump into to a book and dissect it as
we do why don't we talk about what it
could mean even to suggest or to title a
book say that history is over CU Francis
fukiyama is one person and the person
most associated with you know coining
that phrase for a bunch of reasons he
got pretty lucky and this book actually
became a bestseller in I think 92 or so
but he's not the only one to have said
it I think you could arue heiger said it
uh bodard explicitly says it and he
probably agrees with nothing that
fukiyama said well he's Bor he borrowed
it from someone who already said it too
right I mean he borrowed it from Kev who
borrowed it from
Hegel yeah he he'll point that out he'll
say yeah Hegel he got it from Hegel not
in those terms I think we well he's
trying to articulate it in hegelian like
his argument is that yeah Hegel came up
with this and now he's going to use it
to frame his argument
fukiyama is I said can we present this
to normies in a way that's coherent and
then you brought up Hegel which
is the opposite direction always a good
way to clarify things I only brought it
up because you were mentioning a bunch
of other people who said it like haiger
so you started name dropping before
either I was name dropping them in order
to not name drop them stuff instead of
what they said let's try to make sense
of what it might mean to say that
history is ended hegel's philosophy of
history is actually some of the most
readable stuff he's written like out of
his whole U that's some of the most you
know but we're not getting into it right
now yeah I mean it it maybe present it
the easy way and then go back and see
how Hegel is using it he wants to rescue
it from the Marxist interpretation
basically that's the thing right Hegel
and then Marx reinterpreted Hegel by
flipping him on his head now fukiyama
wants to kind of pull the rug out from
underneath the Marxist we're getting
ahead of ourselves here again if you're
listening to this erase all the those
names in your head and I'll just ask you
Eric straight up if you were trying to
explain to someone that history had
ended not saying that you believe it but
if you did believe it how could you put
that in a way that would make sense yeah
if I mean if someone came up to me and
and asked me about this saying you know
I heard this someone was talking about
the end of history and it seems really
confusing to me you know every day I
wake up and look at my phone and it's
the next day the history is it's never
the same day it's we're not trapped in
Groundhog Day movie or anything like
that so what does this mean and I would
say Well it comes from Francis fukiyama
and he without no no you wouldn't say
that okay I would say that liberal
democracy I can do it I can do it I can
do it I want I say that liberal
democracy is the final form of Human
Social organization and political and
economic organization it means liberal
democracy
plus free market capitalism is society
in its final form all history is bending
in its Arc towards this point where we
have liberal democracy combined with
free market capitalism that's what the
end of History
means you're in a Walmart checkout
line and and someone asks you in this
this very ethereal Walmart what is the
end of History mean and you only have
those those five minutes in the checkout
line to explain it without name dropping
would you say it any
differently Eric I don't know if you
want to answer that I'd say you're in it
this is it it's like waiting in this
line forever until you're dead that's
what it is in a [__] Walmart or
McDonald's usually inside of Walmarts
anyway yeah that's what it Walmart is
the end of History that's a I'd say that
nice nice Victor shoot your shot
okay I think I would say um you know how
there's this idea that we as a human
race are progressing right like you know
we used to be in medieval times and you
know we had slaves and we used to
torture people and blah blah blah and
now and over time we as a human race
there's this idea that we come up with
new ideas that are about better ways of
organizing ourselves and treating each
other with respect like we have human
rights you know how like you have if I'm
in a Walmart in America you know how you
have like the first amendment and you
have all these different amendments that
allow you to be
free uh the idea of the end of history
is not the idea that temporal that time
has stopped but rather it's the history
of the ideas about how to organize
ourselves and the end of history is
pointing to this idea that we've now
reached the point where the
ideas about like individual freedom
freedom for everyone they've reached
their maximum point and there's no
longer any need for new ideas we've
reached the end point of those ideas and
all we need to do now is to basically
perfect the the liberal democratic
ideals the promise of like Freedom
individual freedom for everyone and we
just need to basically make those ideas
come more into reality and that process
will probably continue to be difficult
like it's not the end it just means that
the big ideas about how we're going to
be good to each other as human beings in
organized Society that's come to an end
and liberal democracy the ideals of it
meaning all those things in you know the
American
Constitution they're nice things but
they haven't been fully achieved but the
ideas have been so like we have the
ideas and we just need to now bring them
into reality that's a good way to put it
yeah a culmination of human progress in
a collective human history kind of
sense I would phrase this just in terms
of my own predilections I would phrase
it a little bit differently cuz when you
say the ideas I think most people know
what that means but it's kind of
specific here and we we should actually
probably get to the specificity of what
it means but I'd say it differently in
terms of the directions have all been
decided and they've been decided by
enough momentum in One Direction that
it's impossible to conceive of that
being changed yeah it's it's
ideal in Well I this is where I don't
think it's actually ideal I just think
that the decisions have been made
whether they're made with an idea in
mind doesn't really matter it's like at
this point you could have an idea that
the internet is negative and has a net
negative effect on human society it
doesn't matter if you had that idea
though because you can't turn it off
it's like the the direction of
technological development has already
been decided such that you can't reverse
you can't un invent a nuclear bomb might
be my addendum to that I personally feel
that that person in Walmart would would
understand me better than you the ideas
no no like would understand what I meant
better than what you meant okay okay may
good good job then my intent was just to
say or to add that the idea is not the
causal thing here if we treat the state
like a technology that can't be
uninvented that's what I was going for
there's a an inevitability when
something is invented and and taken into
Mass use that the it's irreversible
regardless of the thinking part of it or
the invisible part of it well it it has
an idea aspect to it because it's not
like what we were saying in the
beginning is is an
interesting example of how well what I
said anyway about the things not aging
well you know it's the difference the
movie hasn't changed and yet 30 years
years later we watch it and we say wow
they're like you know they I don't know
they don't treat women very well in the
film you know they representations of
minorities are problematic whereas they
may not have been you know how did this
[__] thing get made kind of thing
right nothing has changed except for
Consciousness right human consciousness
has changed we're aware of these issues
like wokness is a kind of evolution of
ideas or human consciousness people have
kind of collectively we move towards
certain ideas that are you know whatever
Liberty equality and all of those sorts
of things so it's it's yeah there's a
technological aspect to it you know in
in in the sense that science has
developed all of these things that has
made our economy so booming and amazing
but it's really focused on you know the
development of of human consciousness so
the idea of and history being at an end
means we can see what the ideal form of
social organization is and how people
need to sort of think and accept the
ideas at the basis of democratic
principles well can I just quickly real
quick can I just say that um my answer
was also predicated on the person being
like hey I've heard this term thrown
around what do they mean and my
assumption was well let me try to
explain what Francis fukiyama would have
meant by it because I think my
explanation was like a kind of dumb
version of what I think he means right
as opposed to like what you think you
mean right um yeah like I don't if that
makes sense I don't believe it I
actually think that history has ended
but not for any of the same reasons
exactly but I'm just saying like the
person in Walmart would have heard the
termine probably like there's a 99.9%
chance that that that's the way what
they heard is like somehow related to
Francis fukiyama because that's where
the the term is popularized in any sense
of the I would expect that that's what
they were talking about if they said no
I heard it from bodard I would be kind
of delighted interesting I'd be like
Bard yeah B Bard said this and I'd say
wow okay no you haven't heard the
Francis fukiyama version then great
let's have a conversation about that but
no I'd expect somebody to have heard it
from this book that we're talking about
I was not even Bard dropping there I I
would just say it like if I were to
explain to someone having heard nothing
technology would be the best way to say
it you could you can have ideas about
technology and you can say that this one
is bad and this one is good and you know
we should uninvent the car it doesn't
matter you can't like there's no
reversibility when it comes to
developments in that sense and I think
that would be trying to conceptualize
Walmart again that would be the easiest
way to describe an linearity to this is
that you can't undo what's been done and
the momentum still exists there yeah
sorry
primitivists we can't go back to earlier
ways despite who you're who you're
aligning with here we're we're going to
be reading the fukiyama book like it's
it's been
spoiled um and not just that book but I
think like haider's
1966 dur spegel interview said that
history is over as well and his response
is we we criticized it a couple episodes
ago his weird like quasi mystical
Resurrect The Greek Spirit and the
German spirit and all this stuff and but
he says in this 1966 interview after he
said all that crap Like Only a God can
save us and Only a God can save us from
cybernetics is to put it reductively and
God since 1966 has not saved us but I
mean said in those terms he was one to
say at least recognize that history had
ended at least already by
1966 now there's different ideas about
when history ended this book will say
history ended in
1991 um and depending on who you ask
history ended at different times it's
not the kind of thing that ends on a
certain day it's not like something that
dies but more like it dribbles out or
disappears like because there's no more
thought there's only calculation there's
only there's only rational calculation
to get things we want there's no true
thinking maybe for haiger or in in the
philosophy term of this there's no new
events because if we think for a second
what's an event an event is something
not just you know an interaction that
happens in time and space but an event
in the philosophical sense is something
that happens that is kind of unfor seen
meaning you didn't predict it happening
and then it changes the future because
it was
disruptive and to have an end of History
means that there are no events anymore
or events are impossible because nothing
will disrupt the direction that we're
already on and we read like uh Badu a
couple weeks ago who said that changing
history is
impossible from now
on and of course he said because it's
impossible that means it could happen
anyway but but but to say that nothing
can change the direction that we're
moving in that is what it means to say
that history is ended and and that's
important too with that we are moving in
a Direction I mean not believing in
history is a little bit different than
thinking that there's an end to history
I mean I guess not believing in history
is is almost like a Hallmark of nihilism
just saying you know there's no
direction it's it's just it's just
random events it's just random things
happening there's no progress there's no
decline there's just you know relative
good relative bad but none of it's
absolute it just kind of goes the way it
goes maybe that's not believing in
history at all I don't understand the
point of this like like I don't I don't
get again I'm having that feeling that I
mentioned at the beginning whenever
people talk about history or like make
kind of grand remarks about history it's
weird to me it's just like premised on
some kind of an empirical claim that
could just end up being wrong and it's
like yeah also like what do we mean by
what do we mean by things not changing
right so like there's events and I'm
sure there's some kind of U I don't know
if it's bedu or bodard or whoever you're
drawing on will kind of give some kind
of necessary and sufficient conditions
for what what counts as an event right
it's like well did that really change so
what's the thing that's supposed to not
change exactly right cuz you know we
have all kinds of events that happen
like you know the Israel Palestine thing
that was mentioning earlier there's like
9911 arguably I don't know was that a
pseudo event I like I don't know so what
what do we mean here I just I I feel
like I'm I'm in a cloud of confusion and
vagueness maybe put it this way um
history has not always
existed so history itself is historical
at minimum as like a style or a genre of
writing which is often like laid at the
feet of
Herodotus or someone like that but
there's if there's a difference with
modern history or what's generally
called modernity you can kind of see
that for the first time all of history
our historical process became
intelligible intelligible given to a
sort of rationality now there is already
an end of history in something we
haven't mentioned yet but Christianity
Christianity has an esal eschatological
end where you know history is over when
God decides that it is but there's a
difference here I think in that it's
it's now something for us to be able to
figure out in that certain things that
happen some are events some may not be
but they have meaning and there are
underlying laws guiding history right
exactly that's a great point that there
are laws to history laws of Human Social
Development there's actions and then
there's reactions and you can expect
that this is more or less if not a
rational process then at least an
intelligible intelligible process you
know you can look back at it and you can
say this happened for reasons and then
the next thing that happened that
happened for reasons too there are laws
that govern the cause and effect whether
they be ideal reasons whether they be
material reasons whether they be Divine
reasons and there's like a stage Theory
to it as well
like to feudalism then we hit modernity
and capitalism and then according to
Marx the next stage should be communism
let's say right so there's a direction
there's underlying forces and there's
certain stages you can have a stage
Theory and so you reach the final stage
that's the end okay but wait are we
talking about so we are talking about
like regimes it's sociopolitical as
opposed to physical because like social
political yeah like if a if a meteorite
hits the Earth and makes most of the
dinosaurs go extinct this is not an
intelligible event it's a it's an
arbitrary event unless you're some kind
of mystical hermeticist or you're some
kind of theist that believes that God
killed the dinosaurs to make way for
Maman Evolution so that we the pinnnacle
of creation could eventually appear but
Christians do have the eschatology of
you know the end times and that's a
certain end of History that's a
theological perspective so did you know
the the Greeks had a kind of sense of
the end of times as well in their
mythologies right so give me an example
of an EV of a of of a proper event
French reol Revolution okay so that was
okay so that was a proper event the last
one according to Hegel was the Battle of
Y Napoleon against Frederick of Russia
and that was the final event of History
right that's where the ideal form of
social organization became clear and the
end came into view and some of us became
potor because we managed to I say we I
don't know who that is but we managed to
implement the principles that came out
of the French Revolution and were sort
of embodied in this or or open the the
floodgates too in this final battle of Y
between Napoleon and
Russia okay so you think it's impossible
for another event to happen that would
actually change anything in that sense
well one might think that if they
subscribed and change in this case in
that there are ideal Alternatives other
than you know the one that won or the
one that's been set well what's the one
that's been set that depends on who you
ask for haiger it's cybernetics for
fukiyama it's liberal democracy that's
what we're all disagreeing about I guess
wait but cybernetics is not
sociopolitical is it like H yeah for him
it is it's like rational calculation
being the determining factor in how we
make every decision social decision for
the rest of time yeah for Hegel it's the
development of the
state and for Marx again it's the
abolition of capital and yeah I know I
get I yeah I understand that I'm just
like cybernetics it's like a way of Okay
so were things at one point then not
decided based on rational calculation I
guess yeah like the French Revolution
was not based on that it was like based
on what was it based on like I'm just
trying to understand like the boundaries
and borders of these terms because like
it's not clear to me it just it feels a
little over Brad to me like that you can
just Encompass everything Encompass
everything under I mean you're
absolutely right and if you think this
way of thinking is stupid then that's
the reason that you're going to think
it's stupid and this is not the only way
that has ever been thought either about
time if you go to a sort of what we call
prehistory there's like a a cyclical
motion there's no such thing as we need
to organize utilize power and then
change what we're going to do in the
future there's no idea of changing
history whatsoever wait but at the at
the individual level or at the social
level because I feel like I mean going
back to the Greeks like there I mean no
before the Greeks before the the Greeks
are considered part of the West
according to fukiyama so they invented
this [__] so you're saying that like the
Chinese for example like weren't
thinking about like the future about
changing things about power about like
maintaining order no no I mean every
every human for all time has thought
about the future but the future in a
historical sense meaning this is a
malleable thing that can be changed like
democracy
only occurs in one tradition basically
at one time in other cases the chieftain
is the chieftain or the emperor is the
Emperor because some natural forces or
Gods conspired to put that person's
family usually in power and they might
as well be a different species there's
nothing to change that and and you have
that great chain of being around that
time too you have that great chain of
being where it presents a kind of static
view of the human position in the
universe right we're below the Angels
we're above the animals there's no way
to you know raise ourselves up or lower
ourselves until you really new ideas
about this come around in the
Renaissance where you know they look at
you know this amidst this revival of
ancient learning and this rediscovery of
of all these ancient texts and then they
look back at the previous era they look
back at the Middle Ages and go wow like
the Dark Ages eh they they're the one
the people in the Dark Ages didn't know
it as the Dark Ages that came after and
the Renaissance people you know Pico DEA
mirandola for example believed in a kind
of now progress where humans can better
themselves where we actually can surpass
the achievements of the Ancients that
were not
dwarves right and I mean it's so
complicated but you know if I if I were
going to Prime you for a kind of
cultural history class that's what i'
kind of think you'd encounter first is
that you know there's a static vision of
the
universe Middle Ages let's say and then
during the Renaissance that loosens up
and we get a sense of time passing of
progress of developments of new ideas of
of new heights new achievements and that
we can be better off than the people
before us and then
you know that kind of gets folded in
with the enlightenment too and the idea
of scientific progress and the
betterment of The Human Condition right
and and that all supposedly culminates
in again in the end of history when some
ideal form of sociopolitical
organization emerges that we eventually
hopefully
realize in the state in democracy and in
our form of
government and it's extremely immaterial
it's I I call it I call it
idealistically
chauvinist yeah it's it's idealist we
read the dawn of everything book right
and if if we take that seriously The
Davids were saying no these negotiations
were going on like throughout and they
would Evol they would develop they would
change based on you know resources based
on Seasons they would have new social
formations but I think what changes with
the West that I would agree with
is the idea of
history and this comes from in my mind
an eschatological Christianity that
says God made this world set it up and
he set it up to end a certain way he
didn't set it up arbitrarily he set it
up and we're just waiting to get to the
end point of it and this becomes
rationalized by a lot of the
Enlightenment political theorists that
we think of
that now we too have a purpose on Earth
to bring about that end of History give
every justification for civilization to
do anything it wants to anyone who's un
civilized because they don't have
history you know they're outside of the
process so who who the [__] cares what
happens to them yeah that's that's what
the book felt like sometimes is just
pointing out the places that are going
against Western principles Western ideas
yeah I mean I think I think like I think
I sort of feel the same way that I did
at the beginning where like because I
don't feel sympathetic to I just think
that the category of History to make any
Grand pronouncements is just not useful
I just I don't find it compelling I
don't F I don't feel like it clarifies
anything like I think I'm probably
because of that a bit more on the side
of just like there's no such thing as
history there's just things that happen
happen and you know we can kind of
create heuristic ideas about about it we
can kind of talk about because in our
own you know going back to haiger like
we're temporal beings we're like kind of
future oriented and I think because of
that because we are like uh anticipatory
anticipating things we end up kind of
projecting that and making stories about
you know that that can make sense of the
different events because we of the fact
that we just already are future oriented
but I don't think that it's a thing that
exists exactly and and I don't know like
how helpful I mean there there's a
different question in the fukiyama book
that's implicit I think in this which is
just like is liberal democracy like can
we really think of anything
better than you know the most idealistic
version of liberal democracy well that's
basically what he means by and if the
answer to that question is yes then
we've reached the end of History yes I I
understand that but my point is like I
think that this talk of History just
confuses what I think is a much clearer
question which is just like well can we
think of anything better or not like do
we have reasons for thinking and I'm not
persuaded by his argument at all but I
just think like when you bring history
in it for me at least maybe my brain is
just too small but I just feel like this
it's just it's just so broad like I
don't know what to grab on to when
people talk about history I just think I
find it to be
obfuscating okay I think this is great
because everything you agree or you just
said I agree with all of this is made up
it's a a narrative imposed on an
infinite amount of disperate information
composed into a narrative by selecting
what's useful to you yeah so if you're
if you're trying to be empirical about
this this is absolutely useless it means
nothing however yeah I choose to
ironically believe in the idea of
History because everybody else believes
in it if you watch CNN for 10 minutes
not to me no any of them if you watch
Fox News if you watch any news for 10
minutes they have an idea of history and
they will declare it as if it's true
there's no distinction between the right
and left on this point and these are
cistica discourse about what we should
do about X or Y in the present they're
deriving the logic rhetorically at the
very least from their idea of history as
opposed to the other teams okay but what
do you think those ideas are
though in the news because I don't think
they're the same as this I don't think
they're like the fukiyama view of
History I think it's like some other
it's like a much
more much like smaller scale you could
put anything into it you could put
wokeness into it you could put Israel
Palestine into it you could put Russia
into it Russia is bad Ukraine because
Russia is bad Ukraine is good just those
kind of funneling calculations where you
can just declare a moralistic output to
any input is part of The Narrative of
history but the this The Narrative is
what matters here the story about
history is what is history in my mind
yeah I think the best sense you can
really get from the news about what
history is is it's just this infinite
stretch it just goes on forever history
keeps going and going and going and you
know we have to look at you know
economic growth maybe that's one of the
most important factors let's say right
if your GDP is above a
certain state if it's above a certain
level whatever it is like 1.8 or 2.4% or
whatever you're you're doing good
there's growth steady and if you believe
in progress then you believe that
there's a certain something things are
getting better and better and better as
we go along and the the end of history
is really just like asking well does
that progress have an end point like are
we just going to go on forever getting
better until we reach the Jetson or Star
Trek and then even beyond that we're
going to be like Interstellar beings
moving from Galaxy to G or is there like
an end point to it all maybe those
material developments will all occur but
maybe they'll all be just like liberal
democracies we'll have we'll have the
planet of Liberty and the planet of
democracy and we'll have this universe
of liberal Democratic social
organizations all over the universe or
will something new emerge and yeah you
can't really predict it but you got to
have some kind of theory right like if
you want to be a Marxist you got to
bring about the revolution if you want
to be a liberal then you got to promote
ideas of Liberty and equality and
democracy if you want to be a nihilist
don't do anything like it's fine but you
know the these their hypothesis that
Orient us and you can find certain
empirical data to look at it right that
you you find a through line right like
for Hegel it was the development of
freedom for Marx it was the succession
of different modes of production we can
look at feudal production and we can
look at capitalist production and we can
see what's different about them and how
one you know sort of supersedes the
other and maybe we can find clues that
capitalism is kind of collapsing and
coming to an end and then hope that
there's something afterwards and we
don't know but we have a theory about it
so we can act on that and maybe we're
[__] completely wrong I don't think
you need a theory of history at all well
I I don't I don't I don't you need a
theory to get out of bed and go out your
door in the morning at least even just
for making arguments about [__] my
favorite example of this that will be
forever my favorite example is we need
to invade Afghanistan because they put
their women in burkas this was a legit
argument from the time that I became
news conscious they're they're they're
bad to women we need to invade them
that's an idea of history but okay so
that this is where I just think that the
category of history is just not useful
because basically like on this view
history just means like normative
beliefs so like if you think that one
way of living is better for people or I
don't know for and they take the example
of like Ukraine it's like to me it's
like I don't think that there's
anything I mean it just I I guess I just
find it kind of disturbing that a bunch
of people in Ukraine seem to want to you
know join the European Union join and
then like this other country is kind of
coming in and but I don't but that
doesn't have anything to do with history
in my opinion like I mean I guess
implicitly it it does I suppose but to
to me it's more just like a normative
question it's like well it kind of just
seems bad to me that these people want
one thing and then this other Power is
coming in but is that because I I have
like a view of history I mean I guess on
this like really broad definition if
it's it just means normativity then okay
fine I guess yeah well it kind of is
where you draw your Norms from right
like Russia says historically you know
we were an imperialist State and R
Ukraine was part of it so historically
we have a right but that's actually why
I think the you that's why I think the
Russian argument is stupid because it's
like drawing on some his historical
thing it's like to me it's like what do
those people want now it's like let's
just listen to the human beings who are
there right like what do they want it's
like that to me that I don't know what
that has to that's just like my own like
humanistic commitment I guess maybe
that's historical I don't I mean it is
in this but I don't understand what it's
adding like like to to our clarification
of things it's like you just have
normative commitments well you don't
think people don't justify their
decisions on historical precedence right
oh I mean that's where Norms come from
you're right about that I think that's
where the Norms come from they they do
at the patterns in history and we derive
Norms from those patterns and then we
want we think those Norms are good so we
want want to carry them forward I think
that's what the point of learning
history is in the first place like why
else would we read about the French
Revolution if it was completely just
read L of the Rings then okay but but
it's not because I have some view of
like history that it's like has to move
in this direction towards it's like so
for example like I don't think that
people in Russia like they're happy with
Putin like I don't think there's
anything wrong with that I'm just like
okay you're happy with Putin keep Putin
right but these other people don't so
it's not like I don't have a view of
History where I'm like oh like Russia
must eventually lead to this thing it's
like they want to have authoritarianism
forever like I mean that's fine you know
that's you know that's that's what they
want people seem to really like Putin in
Russia cool you know like I'm not I'm
not going to make some Grand
pronouncement about like I'm not a
relativist but I'm also not going to be
like oh we have to go invade them
because history demands it right like
like which is or I don't I you know I'm
not going to say oh we have to have like
Revolution because history demands it
necessarily right like there might be
certain CC ances where people are really
upset uh and then there be like
particular situational reasons where
it's like yeah we do need to like you
know take up arms against the government
right like let's say Ukraine does end up
becoming a part of Russia and you know I
could imagine insurgencies and that'd be
like okay like yeah they don't want to
be there so they should fight to like
not be part of it anymore but I don't
understand what having a theory of
History adds to it like I it's not
because again this is why I just feel
like it's so vague it's so [__] it's
just obfuscating I know you're saying
this but decisions are made and
Justified on this basis all the time
yeah it's good that you wouldn't do that
because people intervene because of
historical [__] all the time oh yes I
agree people okay it comes up all the
time January 6 it's bad because Hitler
did the the the pooch before he came
those are stupid arguments I agree with
you those are stupid arguments I agree
but but I was responding I was
responding to Eric saying you need a
theory of history and I'm just like no
you don't like I don't think you do like
like you can just have situational
reasons for why like January 6 was bad
because I think it threatened like
certain institutional Norms that could
destabilize and it's like most people
want to live in a stable country that
seems bad to like attempt to destabilize
it so for for a lot of people well look
I pushed back on you in in saying at
least these decisions that you're making
about good and bad are very historically
determined as
welled they're intelligible so you can
intelligibly decide
this is a good thing this is a bad thing
but I'm saying
that popularly or
publicly history despite the fact that
most people know very little of it
including myself but it's used as a
justification for any possible action
yes it provides the basis for
understanding what's going on in the
world and that's what a theory is you
have a theoretical understanding right
and that's why some of us are wrong and
some of us are right why did this happen
why did Trump get elected right and then
we come up with all these theories that
are based on historical analysis right
of to why you know the fascist movement
is resurgent in Europe and we have to
use history in order to explain that if
we're just like presentist all the time
we're never going to understand anything
I mean I kind of agree but I also kind
of did like maybe I mean it kind of
Reminds Me Maybe This is an analogous
thing that always irritates me when you
know when people were just calling Trump
a fascist and it's like yeah he had like
maybe some but it's like they're using
that as the argument oras I would rather
just talk about well what are the
specific things that he's doing that you
don't like and why like talk about those
don't just be like he's a fascist and in
a way like I feel like just talking
about
history is like a kind of another lazy
cop out where it's just like okay well
because this other thing happened it's
like well why don't you just talk about
the specifics of the thing that you
think is good or bad and it's like sure
everything is historically rooted but I
don't know I still don't really
understand honestly like what well I I
agree comparing the the trumpian ethos
to Fascism is a little bit of a stretch
it's a little bit dramatic but I mean a
bad comparison is still a kind of
comparison right and it still kind of
orients the way people think about the
whole situation there's authoritarian I
mean you I don't want to have a
conversation about it but like yeah I
think I understand why people made the
comparison I'm just saying like talk
about the specific things that he's
doing and the effects that scare you
right like talk about the specific
things he's like trying to you know he
was he tried to bribe a [__]
political a democratic official to find
him more votes right like that's bad why
is that bad specifically It's like
because it's threatening uh you know the
people's will in that in that in that
Democratic place like sure those reasons
are all like based on historical values
but I'm I'm just not really seeing the
yeah I don't really understand yeah I
just I don't I don't understand you
saying that
the media output when it is reflecting
on current events is irrational it's mot
like it might be irrational it might not
be nevertheless it is the media output
even though you say I don't believe in
this everybody else
does and you are invoking certain
historical products by the way like the
Egyptian pharaohs would never say
something like you're saying that people
have a right to self-governance that
should be guaranteed but if your point
is simply to say that this is irrational
and we should all have political
discussions based on disinterested
rational back and forth argument I mean
I'm sure you know what that sounds like
you're just making up a Utopia sure
people invoke I mean people invoke all
kinds of nonsensical categories to
explain things and I understand like I I
yeah like
I yeah iess I guess I it's just like
when we're trying
to come and make sense of it on a you
know podcast about whatever Theory
philosophy uh you know I'm just trying
to clarify it a little bit and and and
and I'm like well it's not clear at all
you know it's just it's all over the
place so for me it's not useful because
it's just all over the place so we can
describe it like we can say I mean first
of all like it's no surprise that the
media you know whether it's about
history or whether it's about anything
else or like you know normies or people
in general just say all kinds of things
that make no sense that are like related
to Fantasy you know habit whatever
they're just like repeating [__] it's
just of course yeah it's no surprise
here there's nothing new here over the
break I listened to some some Joe Rogan
it's incred this is the most popular
podcast in the world it is incredible
yeah it is he was going on like
um the Sphinx no they are saying they
are saying that the Sphinx is actually
not 2500 years old they are saying that
it could be 30,000 years old because it
would have been facing a different
constellation at at the time oh did you
have that weird historian on who made
that like Netflix show or something that
weird they interpreted the hieroglyphics
to all be myths but what if they were
all
real yeah yeah it's well he cuz he he's
talking about a specific dude though
this like and he's not a reliable source
but there's a guy who's been is it
Ancient Aliens I don't know if it's
Ancient Aliens he made he's like this
this kind of amateur historian
archaeologist journalist and he made an
a documentary series on Netflix and
whole thing is about how like there was
an advanced civilizations that existed
like way more way longer ago basically
like so he would say no no like the
first civilizations weren't 5,000 years
ago they were actually like you know 20
like before the ice age or like during
the Ice Age like that he thinks that
there's I love it see those kinds of
things embody what you were saying about
you know Theory you can just say
anything you want right so how do we how
do we stop that you know you can make
theories that sound plausible and you
can just come up with like batshit
theories like that we can stop it I mean
we can't stop it people are going to
continue to say ridiculous things
forever well I think the historical
evidence the the empirical evidence is
important I mean it's not the end all be
all but it a place where you can falsify
certain things about
your maybe select certain ones over
others if it's said widely and popular
enough that's more important than
whether the thing actually happened or
not like you can bring this up in terms
of documentaries cuz we have a
documentary boom currently mainly
because it's like cheap to produce and
you can use historical footage you don't
have to go out and film stuff you can
put it up especially true you can put it
up on Netflix like exactly but it used
to be that documentaries were reserved
they were they had like a pseudo sacred
place for significant events and
significant topics but now because of
the media scope of the the way that we
interpret history I I would argue we
have to document everything as it
happens we have to have live
documentries that the images are
produced in real time so Taylor Swift in
the very middle of her career can
document the the the rise of Taylor
Swift and publish it herself or the
documentaries about some guy who
catfished someone or documentaries like
you said truth crime unsolved murder in
and ongoing
investigation nothing for us is too
small to be documented in the image and
then if everything is history then
history doesn't really mean anything so
live history is not made of events it's
just made of anything that happens ever
so that I think is the decay of the idea
of History which is something that
you're saying we should have done a long
time ago however history of the capital
H fukiyama doesn't agree with that
fukiyama thinks there is is an idea to
history and we need to like stay stay
true to it stay hold to it not lose it
because if we lose it then we're lost
and why are we going to lose it it's
going to be identity
politics oh yeah he does kind of say
that sort of later like I think his his
new more recent book I forget is it just
called Identity or something I forget if
it's called identity it has it in the
title I think it was more so so far
we're I'm about three chapters into the
book the intro and I don't know like I
you know I've read sections of it I mean
I'm doing my PhD in political science
and I did and I did uh and I did it in
undergrad too I was doing a lot of
political science classes so this kind
of argument is you know the sort of
straussian uh art like school which
fukuyama is sort of tangentially part of
has a huge influence on political
science department so like this has been
kind of in the back of my mind for a
long time but to actually sit down and
and sort of read the book I've never
done but so far in the like in the book
you know I don't know know like the
sense of history that he seems to be
arguing for while I still don't really
agree with his argument it doesn't seem
to be like to like again I I was reading
it more as a normative argument he's
just saying well I think that the
liberal democratic ideals are shown to
be the best ones and he so far in the
first few chapters he's giving all these
sort of historical accounts for why he
thinks that theide ideal are you know
kind of the end of of the history of
ideas and so so it's it's more like well
I think that that it's we can we can
show that the liberal democratic ideals
and like I think that's an interesting
question about like well what does he
mean by that like liberal democratic
ideals right so it's not uh you know oh
I you know the way that capitalism and
liberal democracies exist today is like
the best right like that's not what he's
saying I think a lot of people think
that that's what he's saying but that's
not what he's saying what he's saying is
the ideals are the best ones and the
governments right now are trying to live
up to those ideals and the only thing
that needs to be done is to kind of uh
build on those ideals and make them come
into reality as perfectly as possible if
that's possible at all not that the way
that they exist now is really good it's
just like and I don't know hopefully in
the book later he'll kind of give some
more detailed arguments as to why he
thinks that the liberal democratic
ideals are the best so far he's just
giving historical accounts of showing
the collapse of authoritarian regimes at
in the '90s and the'80s why they
collapsed the weak trying to show that
liberal democracies are much more robust
and I think that obviously looking at it
now in hindsight I think uh it's a
little he's a little wrong although I
will say I kind of forgot how recently
like Portugal and Spain were actually
like fascist regimes like I kind of
forgot that like did you say that I
think Portugal only like got democracy
in like the 80s and I was like [__] I
didn't I kind of forgot about that and
like Franco I think left in like the 70s
or something in Spain so it was kind of
cool for that reason but I don't think
that I agree with his argument so far
but I just want to get clear on what
he's actually saying right like he's
talking about the liberal Democratic
ideas I I think you're you're hitting
the nail on the head there we just need
to connect it all together like I'm
about where you are I I haven't read the
whole thing I'm about where you are a
few chapters in and yeah he's he's put
forward this theory that history is
culminating in the liberal democratic
ideal and that so in these first couple
chapters he's he's showing us now why
the liberal democratic ideal is
ascendant what and why these
authoritarian regimes you know
authoritarianism on the right fascism
authoritarianism on the left communism
as he has it why these are are weak and
and failing over the 20th century
despite a lot of setbacks and major Wars
and horrific events why things are
generally progressing towards the
emergence and the
universalization and let's say the
concrete
realization of these liberal democratic
ideals so you know we are we're
following his argument here right and
like I I just throw in a quick quote
right just to substantiate it like he's
saying he's not talking about the
occurrence quote the occurrence of
events
even large and Grave
events that's not what he's saying is
coming to an end sorry end quote but
he's saying what's coming to an end is
history with a capital H that is quote
history understood as a single coherent
evolutionary process that's what he
means a single coherent evolutionary
process When taking into account the
experience of all peoples in all times
so it's a world historical like Hegel
says it's World historical it's world
history All Peoples at all times and
he's saying this is coming to an end
with the emergence of again modern
liberal democracy and technologically
driven capitalism is where we're
encountering this end of history now and
he even says you know some even after
the end of History some places are going
to be like America po hisorical while
other places are going to be still his
IAL and there may be conflicts between
po historical regimes and regimes that
are still mired in history and leaning
towards authoritarianism of one shade or
another but and so he's saying so events
aren't going to end even big horrific
events like covid climate change Wars
he's not saying those are going to end
he's just saying all of that is just
going to be now again what we've been
saying random events now they're just
going to be be random calculative events
technical problems to be solved not you
know these big questions about who are
we where did we come from where are we
going like those questions are in a way
going to become irrelevant after the end
of history and it's just going to be
Technical Solutions to problems that's
what I sort of got so I think that's
where we are when we're going through
this that seems that seems right I was I
I wrote a paper in undergrad kind of
about this that things are probably just
going to always change because human
beings can never be satisfied like that
that you know they're going to get bored
basically like I'm dumbing it down here
so and in a way like thinking about the
way things are now it's like I do feel
like you know we're seeing the younger
generation in the US for example more
and more being interested in
alternatives to democracy right they're
like well maybe you know maybe we should
do like more right-wing authoritarian
stuff like maybe we need like you know
these Tech Bros who are like maybe we
need do we need like a tech Lord to just
like run everything and I just feel like
human beings they just always think the
grass is greener on the other side and
they're just going to keep oscillating
back and forth between different kinds
of regimes I think they're going to be
like well maybe authoritarianism is
better because and it's interesting by
the way that fukuyama says I think
pretty early in his book that he sees
the right-wing threat as more dangerous
than the leftwing one to the stability
of liberal democracy because he said
that he because he has this whole
argument about thumos which I thought
was interesting right he like a good and
he always he always draws on draws on on
always always they're always [__]
bringing in
play but like he has this whole struggle
for recognition argument and uh it was
just funny to me that the reason I'm not
saying I agree with it but it was funny
to me that the reason why he thought
that the right was more dangerous or
something is because the right is better
at drawing on some kind of Thum modic
kind of like membership or or it's like
you know they're better at talking about
like your identity it's like you know
you're part of this state and it's like
you should you should like you know
you're part of this race this master
race and he's like well that's more
dangerous than the leftwing Cosmopolitan
communism one because that one is not as
clearly drawing on thematic you know
energies or something and it's odd that
you say that too because it seemed like
his argument was that during the 20th
century communism was the bigger threat
like he was say like fascism was just
ridiculous but after the collapse of
Communism now like just fascism is the
only sort of threat communism is never
coming back it's gone and done dead and
buried Marxist leninism is Thoroughly
discredited and undesirable universally
to all people now that's I'm putting it
maybe a little stronger terms than he
did but he basically says that and I
probably should have said too by the way
that thumos I'm assuming that most of
our listeners know what that is but it
was you know the Greek word for a kind
of Spirited like Civic love like of of
your fellow like of your of your fellow
like it's almost like the kind of
marshal or militaristic
like identity love it's like love of
your nation love of your fellow your
spiritedness exactly yeah it's like you
have your rational part where you
calculate how to get what you desire you
have your Desiring part which is you
know the objects you desire and then you
have your thumos which is like your sort
of yeah your liveliness your spirit
you're you're the human part of your the
sort of interesting part I guess the
spirit Plato has his ordered his
properly ordered human being and there's
a a Chariot master and then two horses
one of the cha Char or one of the horses
sorry is the thumos which is your
passion your spiritedness and then the
other one is your appetites your just
base needs desires and reason is the
driver ideally at least IDE like your
your reason is supposed to drive and
steer the other two yeah exactly and we
we're going to get yeah we're we're
almost at time here but we're definitely
going to get further into this and read
it more carefully in uh in future
episodes yeah my my quote was from the
preface by the way so yeah we're really
far into it yeah I just wanted to say
though that very few people explicitly
denounce history even of intellectual
Persuasions it's a it's a Hallmark
of the right it's a Hallmark of the left
oh we are so historic
Christians zionists which comes up
recently like the only people who
actually
explicitly denounce the idea of an
intellig intelligible history are
nians and that's only some that's what I
said earlier nihilism and that's only n
is not a n let's get out of here and
this is or this is not all nians either
because like the the the full title of
the book is the end of history and the
last man which is a nche concept the
last man yeah so it's uh it's 20th
century nians that really come against
this idea of the intelligibility of
history and yeah I don't know I don't
know who' you who' you put into that the
masters of Suspicion you know Freud in
some cases bodard for sure but Tai who
don't worry everybody Victor's going to
read it and we're going to get to Bai as
well B I don't want to read that at all
you're you're going to this is part of
your job now but we we do have some
entangling to do here it's so long it's
like 500 pages the intelligibility of
history and like we we almost all agree
on it I think when I look around and I
see the arguments for even the new
accelerationism or whatever silicon
Valley's Theory Bros okay so does
history just mean like we can take
action and make things better like is
that all it is yes okay well that's the
interesting thing what pills just
history being intelligible that's the
interesting thing because right we've
already said history appears as just a
chaotic mass of things and events and
data and all kind of documented in this
big messy his so how do we impose order
on it like what's the through line like
how do we look at ancient history up to
the modern day and impose order on that
chaos
right and and again I I've already
hinted at this right so hegel's idea is
tracing the growth of the idea of
freedom right so Asiatic regimes had the
idea of freedom but only for one so they
didn't really have freedom at all one
per then the ancient Greeks and Romans
they had more of an idea of freedom they
were free they believed in freedom but
only freedom for some right slaveholding
Society they only believed in Freedom
for some and then we get to the sort of
Christian liberal idea
where everyone is equal and everyone is
free and so once we learn that we become
free and we know it but it's not
perfectly realized so there's still some
work left to do in history and that's
the point we got to bring about that
concrete historical universality well
I'm I'm probably [__] the terms up
but yeah this is St Augustine on like
how to bring the city of God to Earth as
opposed to for example The Iliad The
Iliad there's no reasons that the Greeks
won it wasn't it wasn't because they
were more moral it wasn't because they
were better the whole thing was a
squabble between the gods of Troy and
the gods of the Greeks and they were it
was an irrational mess and then the
outcome just happened to be faded or
they even have a declen view like the
Golden Age Silver age Bronze Age it kind
of goes down everything's in the shadow
of these initial events that kind of
kicked off the k chaos of everything
else that follows and then we kind of
return full circle in the end so there's
no no progress really and the full
circle idea of cyclical history this is
just fate like it doesn't matter what
you try to reorganize it doesn't matter
if you change things it doesn't matter
if you sit down and reason about what
the best Society is because the end will
be the same regardless of the path you
choose that is not a historical View and
you see that in Greek literature as
opposed to you know Athenian
philosophy and I was even reading um
Michael Hudson he's a a Marxist
historian Economist and he was saying
that um in ancient I think it was
Sumeria every Sumerian king when they
came into power would kind of wipe the
Slate completely clean and start fresh
which means they would forgive all the
debt right so as the rule progress of a
king people would agriculturalists and
small holders would get into more and
more debt and the debtors would take
more and more and and centralize a lot
of the ownership and then a new king
would come in wipe the Slate clean
return ownership to people and and kind
of restart the whole process again and
he said it's only when we get to ancient
Rome H when the debt starts to not be
forgiven with each new regime that comes
into play and I think he was talking
here about the transition from the
monarchy to the republic or maybe I'm
thinking the Republic to the uh Imperium
but he says this is sort of the first
time in history we see sort of debt
carrying over from generation to
generation and people being held in in
sort of intergenerational
servitude rather than maybe the simple
just like dehumanizing view where some
people are slaves and others don't but
it was really interesting he was
actually kind of talking about this like
end of History thing and that but yeah
yeah going from that cyclical history to
going to kind of linear progress that
was a big huge intellectual achievement
and that's not something to you know
that's again I said at the beginning
that's something you'd learn if you were
taking cultural history and you got to
your Renaissance section the invention
of History we might call it the
Renaissance invented the term the Dark
Ages in order you say we have surpassed
that yeah I mean I think I kind of agree
with the idea that these like this kind
of broad like making Grand
pronouncements about history like is
really it's kind of nonsensical but I
think on the other hand I've just been
reflecting on my own beliefs but like
what's the relationship between smaller
scale cuz I guess the thing that I find
myself a little bit confused by is like
what's the relationship between like I
guess real events real changes but then
like the thing that I think I do believe
and in my own work I think I in some
ways I spend time in my own research
talking about these things which is like
small scale things that could make
people's lives seemingly better right
but is that because it's like some I
don't know like for example providing
people I mean this isn't what I talk
about in my work but like providing and
making sure everyone has health care for
free right like I don't know is that
some kind of like myth of progress or is
that just like a general observation of
just like well if we do this how about
getting rid of homelessness right like
how about trying to find different ways
of like having people not freeze to
death in the streets of Toronto it's
like some people might be interested in
trying to solve that problem right like
and I and I happen to believe that it
would be good if that didn't happen
anymore right so is that because I have
some Grand Narrative of History because
I'm I don't want to make any Grand
pronouncements like in fact I [__]
hate philosophy that gets obsessed with
making these Grand pronouncements
defining the age like I think all that
shit's a [__] waste of time well I
don't think it's a waste of time I just
find it uninteresting um but you know to
me like the more fine grain political
social problems I do have a belief that
we can make the world better for those
things right when I'm talking about
something specific but what's the
relationship between that belief and
then this kind of big Renaissance
narrative that you guys are talking
about about history progress right like
is it only possible for me to have that
belief because I believe in a grand
Narrative of History I don't think that
I do okay but are you saying that I have
to either you believe in this Grand
Narrative of history or you have to
basically just be like a nihilist like
are those my only
options I don't think so and we can get
into the historicality of your beliefs
later not now but one of the arguments
that people make for healthare is people
have a right to health care so the
entire debate around rights is
extremely historical progress minded you
know the fact that these should belong
to people at all times regardless of
where they live regardless of the
society in which they live
it it's it's actually a historical in
that sense only if you frame it in
rights by the way I was teaching a class
of law Justice and rights to students
last semester and they were all very
surprised when I had to break it to them
then in Canada there is no right to
healthcare it was just legislation that
was passed right so there's nothing in
the charter that says that they have a
right to healthare absolutely nothing so
like that legislation could be pulled
right and it's just a piece of
legislation that was passed for you know
reasons in the 60s and70s
see that what what you're describing
there I think is a historicizing view of
of well rights or rights to or access to
whatever it's a historicizing view right
which the alternative what you're asking
about the alternative to any kind of
History whether it's Grand history like
this or whether it's kind of micro
history in the style of well Grand
history another good example of grand
history would be the French School of
historians right the the and the the
anal School the long dur people right
they do the big Grand periodizing
history which is helpful when you're
trying to teach students about ancient
history not so much about modern but
then there's the micro history but then
the alternative to that is just
naturalizing right like you believe
human rights let's say are just natural
Eternal always there right so it's kind
of too philosophical naturalism would be
maybe an alternative to say that well if
I have like and it makes sense to me too
like if I have the right to happiness
and and and to pursue my desires and and
freedom from violence arbitrary violence
then I'm then humans must have always
had that right but no that's not I mean
well I'm not a naturalist so I say no
that's not always been the case oh yeah
I don't believe that either haven't
always thought that way human rights are
a kind of historical achievement right
so and then I think as Scholars who are
maybe more on the qualitative side we're
not doing this big quantitative economic
periodizing history we we do more
qualitative micro history and so when
you do say healthc care reforms then you
want to go in and talk to people and see
is this really affecting your life is
this like you're just kind of ignoring
the big do you feel like you're a
citizen of a modern liberal democracy
now no you don't do that to people you
just go in and ask them qu you do the
kind of qualitative studies to me
there's just particular problems that
we're trying to solve in particular
circumstances and I don't know I don't
have any Grand Vision of like you go
into the archives and you reconstruct in
great detail some very specific event
and you try to get to the qualitative
Everyday Life part of it rather than
sort of what its position is in the
grand scheme of things which is an
alternative way of doing history again
Carlo Ginsburg is a is a name you could
look up for this but Victor I can
explain I think why the it of what
you've just
proposed is that there's no way for you
to convince anyone else that you're
right but you you can appeal to empathy
but that would be it you said I Victor
brazone feel like people should have
access to healthare and that people
shouldn't be
homeless they should have access to
healthare and they should not be
homeless sure no no but I mean that's
your feeling the opposition can just say
you know what I don't feel like giving
my money to that so no but if you say
they have a right to if you can convince
enough people that there's a right to
healthare that also means that you have
the right to reappropriate the resources
so that even the people that can afford
it and we can oppose these
reforms so the convincingness of this
whether you're a whether you're a
progressive liberal or whether you're a
conservative the idea behind it is that
this is not my my personal idea this is
not my personal feeling there's a
historical justification and I can
justify the fact that people have a
right to health care which also gives
the state a right to reappropriate
resources in order to provide for that
the justification often or almost always
comes in this kind of language of
history or from a history not a real
history by the way but an ideal history
yeah I mean I I I totally get that I
mean that's kind of like the the nii and
Will To Power it's like well it's just
it's just like me imposing my will you
know or like all the people who seem to
want Healthcare right imposing their
slave morality will on the few who don't
want to pay for it or whatever right I
mean that's just that's fine that's fine
I mean Mo most people want it so yeah in
a way it's like you're making a
statement about something like let's
take Martin Luther King's sort of
statement you know the AR The Arc of
History bends towards Justice right in a
way you're making a statement about what
history is but in another sense that's a
rhetorical tool if you can convince
people that the Arc of History bends
towards Justice and then you can
convince people that you know having
Access to Health Care coverage is just
then you can start a movement on that
basis if you can convince enough people
so we can oppose these reforms in
Ontario that want to gut our Health Care
system because it's too expensive and
raising taxes and blah blah blah we have
private donors that can cover all that
anyway hey whatever whatever whatever uh
you can oppose all that say no we
shouldn't throw our health care System
to the dogs of the free market because
that would be unjust that would take
Health Care away from people make
waiting times longer make it more
expensive etc etc and that's all unjust
we should do the right thing we should
do the just thing yeah and then if
you're trying to get elected you say
they're trying to get healthare they're
immoral I'm trying to provide health
care I am moral so yeah and then the
other side says they're trying to raise
your taxes is and they're
immoral I mean it's still The Clash of
worldviews but at least it's not like
the nihilist politician goes in and say
none of this [__] matters anyway just
elect me well I mean you can you could
be the Democratic politician you could
just say like I'm going to do the things
that you want do people want healthcare
does the majority and it's like you just
say okay well I'm just about you can
convince people to want things to a
degree you can convince we we're
forgetting about ideology which I think
FR Francis just has no concept of
ideology this is just a a rational
intelligible process of rational
self-interested actors calculating
what's best for them but you know you
you could conceive of a of a political
scenario where the politician will say
hey you you rich people I will give you
guys all health care I'll cover all your
health care as long as you convince me
to convince the rest of these idiots
that they don't actually want healthcare
for sure for sure it's a totally wild
hypothetical scenario of course of
course yeah and it all happens in the
free market right for fukuyama I guess
you say you're pursuing your rational
self-interest in the free market and
then the economist wonks and and
technocrats can look at patterns of
behavior and and and try to help people
along something like that say Okay lots
of people want this so we should put
aside you know State resources to help
increase this or make this easier or
better or whatever yeah for sure I mean
I would say to some extent I'm I'm
probably a moral anti-realist like I
just don't really think that there's
such thing but but I think that what I
just happen to find interesting is like
you know kind of you could use the
conent distinction between like a
categorical imperative and a
hypothetical imperative right it's like
to me it's like these moral or these
social problems I think to for me just
philosophically depend on a bunch of
hypothetical imperatives meaning like if
we want everyone to have Healthcare well
how do we figure that out now the fact
that the reasons why people want it I
don't think that's really like
answerable philosophically because just
as you said right you can convince
people you can say like you know and I
don't think that moral morality is like
real it's just like a bunch of desires
that this is one thing I think that we
all agree on in the three of us at least
is that we are anti- idealist and
anti-realist but you're saying that the
the rhetoric should be held to a
standard of rationality because
rationality is worthwhile whereas I'd
say the rationality is just the thing
that convinces people it's not that's
not an idea either there is no idea well
I'm not even talking about the
rationality for I don't I don't think
that you can give a rational answer for
like
morality but you can just look around
and be like okay well it seems like
there's this so people this thing that
people perceive as a social
problem how could we go about Sol how
could we solve deal technical question
right it's like it's like how do we let
me let me just read this it's a good
thing to have close to the end of the
episode because this this I think we're
all I think we are more fukuyama than we
suspect maybe that's a bit of the
postmodern influence but I think we are
a little more fukiyama than we're
willing to admit here's what he says
near the end of the the article from
1989 he writes this the end of History
will be a very sad time the struggle for
recognition the willingness to risk
one's life for a purely abstract goal
the worldwide ideological struggle that
called forth daring courage imagination
and
idealism will be replaced by economic
calculation the endless solving of
technical problems environmental
concerns and the satisfaction of
sophisticated consumer demands in the
post-historical period there will be
neither art nor philosophy just the
Perpetual caretaking of the Museum of
human history and he talks about the end
quote and he talks about the Nostalgia
for those times where we can throw our
lives away to causes that are greater
than ourselves blah blah blah but but
like yeah what you were just describing
right all we really want to do is just
look around and solve the [__]
problems like stop the wars get rid of
hunger and poverty like how can we do
these things we don't need these big
abstract ideas because these problems
are concrete affecting people now right
Justice delayed is Justice not served
right so how do we go about fixing these
problems without all of this baggage and
I think
unfortunately it's not as easy as
fukiyama seems to be suggesting oh yeah
I mean it's incredibly complicated big
abstract ideas that people come in with
people love those ideas too they're very
attractive to them yeah especially when
you're a young person and as you get
older maybe you get a little less
patient for these sorts of things but
when you're younger they're they're sexy
they're they're shiny there things
people rally around they get you they
get you into communities they make you
feel good you're part of a movement
you're part of something greater than
yourself but in the POS historical world
that [__] ain't G to fly no more but is
are we ever going to reach this potor
time is really the question I guess to
be continued because we have more of the
book to read and I have to go so and
we're at we're at time just about but I
thought that would be good to end with
yeah I mean end there there's there's a
lot in there I I hav't that quotes from
the paper you said cuz that's not from
the book I don't think right no no
that's from the from the 89 paper in the
National the essay that ended up that
ended up um inspiring the book cuz the
the paper inspired the book but the book
I don't think it really wants to go in
that direction you can kind of see where
his Rand funding or Rand support is
coming in there a little bit but maybe
we'll we'll get to it anyway next
episode yeah we're going to cover
that like I've been mentioning
throughout B Dillard
has has a a Counterpoint to this but he
makes the same point ultimately just in
a different way that all events here to
for will be simulated there's not going
to be any real effectual events because
we are within the end of history and
then we can maybe decide when history
ended looks like it's I mean I'm sitting
at this is happened sometime around the
early 60s but I'm going to have to I'm
not certain on this we're going to have
to Media AG we're going to have to be
able to convince some people otherwise
it's not real anyway this has been pilp
pod 151 end of History 1 if you want the
full series it's going to be coming out
between here the public feed and uh
patreon so become a patron yeah part two
is going to be a patron episode so yeah
every every other one back and forth
uh we will we will talk at you soon I
think we we opened the can of worms
sufficiently here which is uh yeah I
agree going to be fun I'm interested to
see see whether we can convince Victor a
little more of the historicism of his
views though I'm sure there's
historicism I just think it's
uninteresting like I it's just well then
maybe we can get you fired up about it a
little more you have to make me you have
to convince me that there's like
something philosophically interesting
there cuz so far sounds like kind of
trivially true like but I don't know how
you have historical Ro like to me from
the outside this seems what political
theorists do is just this
stuff well we'll have to wait till the
next episode to find out challenge
accepted all right see you later guys
and everyone
else yeah
[Music]
later